Hi, do you want to see a video that I made?
- No thank you so much.
It's just 4 minutes.
Do you want to see a video that I made, maybe?
No?
It's … It's about refugees from Eritrea.
Came to Israel, no?
This weird guy with the funny accent
who harasses people in the street is me.
Itamar Rose.
Creator of
satirical political videos
in which I get into character.
We are coming to you live
during a missile attack on Netanya.
And deal with racism, militarism,
and other pleasant issues..
I've always believed that my videos could
touch people,
change their perspective,
and maybe even make a change.
You want to see a video that I made?
All I needed is an audience
a stage.
And then came YouTube.
This is what happens
when you give everyone a voice.
A chance to be heard.
And a stage to be seen.
That voice that thought it didn't matter,
it can start a movement.
YouTube promised to give everyone a voice.
An amateur singer with no agent...
An experimental body artist.
An alternative pianist.
And even an oppressed people
craving for change.
YouTube's promise
has swept us of our feet.
Hey you guys it's Jules DIY.
And today...
it is my first ever video.
100 views.
My God.
That's big.
Yea, YouTube.
Google announced they are buying YouTube website.
The CEO of Google Calls it
"The next step"
in the evolution of the internet”.
What is happening to my views?
They get lower and lower
and lower and lower.
So what happened between us and YouTube?
I just don't have enough fans,
I need more.
YouTube has been deleting clips and channels
of war crimes.
Done! Fuck YouTube.
I'm out.
Fuck my YouTube channel.
Fuck you all.
This is Bullshit.
Today terror inside YouTube headquarters.
What drove a YouTuber so far
as to shoot YouTube employees
and then kill himself.
We have a report of subject with a gun
they heard 7 to 8 shots being fired.
A long time before all this happened
I started my journey from a simple desire.
It's a cockroach
I just wanted to go viral on Youtube...
Girl and Horse,
Great Bond.
what the fuck.
So what the hell do millions see in this video,
of a woman petting a horse?
What was I missing?
The creator Itamar rose.
OK, my videos were shown in museums and in the news.
But in Youtube, where I can really make a change
But in YouTube,
where I can really make a change,
I'm a failure.
you are
I have no impact.
What do they know that I don't?...
So I pack my bags
and go on a global journey,
to talk to viral video stars,
find their secrets of viral success
and to become viral myself.
T...
take...
took...
tur... tur.
The accent, I have a very strong Israeli accent.
You think you can help me?
Think. -Yeah.
- Think.
Thank you for meeting me.
I'm Mr. Rose.
- Mr. Rose.
Mr. Rose.
Rose.
Do you know... how do you bark?
Like a dog.
- Woof.
Roof.
This is an American dog.
Right, an American dog.
Try to imitate that.
Roof.
Woof.
Now with my fluent English
and my endless charisma
I'm going to break the internet.
Yo motherfuckers I'm coming!
like me without views
it's like flower without rain.
I will crumble.
So if you broke the internet
or made it on YouTube,
please contact me, help me.
OK, only 227 views.
But sometimes it's the quality...
one of my viewers was a legendary YouTube star
who invited me to learn his secrets.
Bear?
Hey.
- Hi.
Hey. How are you doing?
Nice to meet you.
So this view is the view from the film.
Yeah.
From the Double Rainbow video.
Okay. So, so I saw this view.
I shot it right here.
What, here?
- Yeah.
Where it starts, where the video starts,
I'm standing right there.
Yeah.
Well, I'm walking this way,
the video is going the whole time.
When I get to right here, there's no tree,
and I see the whole thing,
that's the video.
Whoa, that's a full rainbow.
All the way.
Double rainbow.
Oh my God,
it's a double rainbow all the way.
Whoa. That's so intense.
Whoa ho ho ho, oh my God,
oh my God!
Oh my God!
Whoo!
Double rainbow
all the way across the sky!
Oh my God.
What does this mean?
I wasn't doing them because
I was famous or anything.
I was just doing them because...
it's a safer place to put my... my...
my content.
It's also a way for me to prove
that the things that I say are true,
because it doesn't sound real.
God touched me, he knocked me...
when he touched me,
he knocked me to the ground,
and then he started speaking to me
and through me.
It was like I saw..
The burning bush.
That was what the rainbow was.
Maybe God is not God.
Maybe God is Google or YouTube.
No, that's a tool that God uses
to touch people.
YouTube?
- Yeah.
Double rainbow all the way
across the sky
ye ye ye ye ye
so intense
it's made me an icon and a meme,
and a living legend.
And it just keeps going,
like I'm getting more famous.
I want to bring out to the stage tonight
the invincible,
most famous discoverer
of the double rainbow.
Please join us, Yosemite Bear!
Double rainbow all the way 'cross the sky.
Yeah, yeah,
so intense.
Double rainbow all the way 'cross the sky
I want to be like you.
Yeah.
- I want to go viral
and to feel great about it.
The first thing is, you have to not want it.
Yeah, but I want it.
Then it can't happen.
Then it will never happen to you.
I want you to look in my eyes.
Yeah.
Tell me if you see this viral seed
that is going to grow.
You have to let go.
You have to not want it.
I am doing it for God,
to serve my fellow man.
And when you do that,
you become very powerful.
You affect humanity's consciousness
from now on.
Whenever someone sees a rainbow,
they're going to think of this, right?
Who does that?
God.
Okay, listen.
So the guy uploaded his video
on January 2010.
Yosemite, yeah?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
- Yes, we're talking about Yosemite, right?
Nothing happened.
Jimmy Kimmel tweeted:
"My friend Todd has declared
this funniest video in the world,"
"he might very well be right."
And actually, just after,
it became viral.
It definitely couldn't happen
without Jimmy Kimmel.
Now, whether Jimmy Kimmel is God or not,
I don't know,
but Jimmy Kimmel is our gatekeeper.
What is gatekeepers?
The gatekeepers would be an entity,
an organization a person that control information.
Who are the people that can start
manipulating and influencing and controlling
the information in order for it to go viral.
Every network has different leaders,
has different gatekeepers.
It's making my work here easier,
because connecting God
is not my strong side.
I think it will be much more easier for you
to find those Jimmy Kimmels
and make it viral because of them.
So virality isn't the voice of God
or the voice of the people
it's managed and navigated
by the gatekeepers.
Those standing at the gates
signaling right or left
to fame or into oblivion.
Next house is the
director Quentin Tarantino,
director of Kill Bill, Pulp Fiction..
I'm looking for Ellen DeGeneres.
You're looking for her house?
Yeah, I'm looking for her house,
I want to deliver her a message.
Here?
- Yeah. Does she know you're coming?
Yeah, yeah.
Can I read you a letter
and you can tell me if it's good or bad?
I want to be in Ellen DeGeneres' show.
Aha.
So I'm leaving her a letter.
Sure, read it.
Read the letter.
"Dear Ellen:"
"My name is Itamar Rose
and I'm a YouTuber from Israel."
"I've been creating satirical videos
for the past decade."
"I wanted to become a famous YouTuber"
"but I'm a failure."
This is true.
"Please tweet my channel
and I will be famous."
"For you, it's just a tweet,"
"for me, it's a matter of life or death."
It's a good letter?
That's a nice letter.
I think it's very sweet,
it's to the heart, it's good.
Put it under the gate.
I'll put it under the gate.
I would pin the letter to the shirt
and put that up.
Okay.
Cat week! Cat week!
I found some cat videos to prove
that cats can teach us things,
very, very important things.
For instance...
I watch meaningless cat videos on 'Ellen's show'
and I get it.
even if she read my letter,
my political videos had no chance.
If I want to pass the gatekeepers
I need to adjust.
to be less meaningful.
Cat week! Cat week!
So how I can try not to say anything?
After ten years of making political videos
how the hell will I create a video without meaning?
So I go back to the video that drove me nuts
this time as a source of inspiration…
Maybe I will just copy it?
After all, You don’t change a winning horse.
Is it closed?
- It's closed.
I'm looking for a moment of truth
between you and the animals. Okay?
My wife offers to be the girl
and find me some animals.
Now I just need a great bond.
Anna, this isn't working.
I'll get you another outfit.
Sexy...
It's like a farmer's outfit.
This is a farm, after all...
All the farmer women wear these.
Like this?
Yeah.
Let's see if it works.
Give him access.
Access? How?
Think of something.
You think this'll go viral?
Very viral.
After spending a decade in making my political videos
a 22 second video bypasses everything I did easily...
Is the secret of virality not to say anything?
You cannot argue with facts.
It turns out that the great bond between Anna and the goat
moved hundreds of thousands in India,
Pakistan and Saudi Arabia.
I'm not a racist, all clicks were born equal.
I stare at the rising numbers.
With a message or without
I need more
I need millions!
It's time to take out the heavy guns,
my biggest viral asset. Michael
my sweet son.
After getting almost more than 2 million views..
I continue with my motto
if you cannot understand them, copy them.
I realize that people uploaded
all their home videos to YouTube
for everyone to see,
share the child's fall...
Share the touching lullaby,
and even you can become a viral star.
Ow!
Ow, Charlie.
So I try with Michael all kinds of viral combinations.
Ouch!
Michael disappoints me.
Instead of spitting the lemon,
he swallows it eagerly.
Take it away, it's not working.
Now he'll cry
because we took the lemon away.
Michael looks bored from copying viral videos.
Maybe he's more into politics, like me.
I show him historical
and political figures.
There are faces that you reject
with no explanation...
and a face that you like immediately,
that just makes you happy when you see it.
As a father it was hard to see
that Michael is a self-hating Jew
but for the sake of the experiment
I follow his heart's desire.
Adolf.
Adolf, where are the Jews?
Like this?
I upload Baby Hitler's video.
It gets decent views
and sparks a debate.
But it still doesn't get me
to the next level.
So I visit one of the top viral kids
to get some tips.
How did it go?
I didn't feel anything.
Yeah.
Kinda felt good, didn't it?
Is this real life?
Yeah, this is real life.
Okay, now...
now I...
I have two fingers.
Stay in your seat.
I, I feel funny.
Why is this happening to me?
It's okay, Bud,
it's just from the medicine.
Okay?
Is this going to be forever?
No.
No, it won't be forever.
This becomes one of the most legendary
viral videos of all time.
"David after Dentist."
You know that video?
You're gonna launch one of the most
successful viral videos of all times.
David, put that down.
I feel funny.
Why is this happening to me?
I can't see anything.
Stay in your seat.
Hi.
Hi. How are you?
- I'm Itamar.
I'm David Devore. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Come on in.
- Thank you.
It just was back...
this was back in 2008.
We didn't have a YouTube channel
or anything like that,
the only reason he put the video on YouTube
was so he could get the link
to send it to the family.
Oh, okay.
- That was the only intention.
And then Sunday we looked at it.
At halftime.
- And it was 10,000 views.
And we were like, what's going on?
And we never sent it to anybody.
We didn't send it to one person,
and then...
- By Tuesday...
Wednesday or Thursday,
it was somewhere between
3 and 4 million views.
But we were like, worried,
we were like, why did this happen?
You know.
We even thought of taking it down.
So what people told you about the video,
when you put it? -Oh, boy.
They wanted to call the police,
they wanted to put me in jail,
and... -You're serious?
- Oh, I'm very serious.
You can understand why some people think
that's exploiting the child,
not good for him, can't you?
It's been a very... it's been a very
positive experience for our family.
Why has it been positive,
what's positive about it?
Tell me what the positive is?
It's put them through private school
and we're hoping that it'll pay for
some of David's
or all of both boys' college.
That's what we're hoping.
We kind of...
It's kind of found money,
like winning the lottery,
so we can't complain too much.
He doesn't need reminding, he's...
he is who he is,
he's pretty level-headed,
he doesn't...
You know.
Do you feel it changed you?
No. I still think I'm the same.
But, I mean, I've never really lived
where I wasn't famous off a YouTube video.
And what you want to do in your life,
you have an idea?
Psychology.
Like the chemical reactions in the brain,
that's interesting to me.
Like when people go insane,
like what happens in their brain
that makes them go insane and stuff.
I believe that David's family
would have removed the video
if they didn't earn all that money
from YouTube
YouTube updated the dream
and offered everybody the chance,
not only to be famous,
but also to get rich from their
intimate family moments.
So Parents around the world
that chased the dream
started documenting their kids,
looking for those dramatic situations.
When they're hurt...
You'll be fine.
Look at me.
- I see you, I saw you.
When they cry...
Help!
Help! Help!
Somebody!
I can't feel my bottom lip.
When they are operated.
Ouch!
All to recreate David's success.
And so, even an abdominal operation
for a small child
Has become a play begging for our clicks.
Hally, you want me to put this
on YouTube, right?
Put it on YouTube!
What?
- Put it on YouTube!
Clicks that are worth a lot of money
for YouTube.
On Monday Google announced
that they were buying the YouTube website
for 1.65 billion dollars.
Our next guest is a big reason why.
Back. Back.
Double, one, two.
One, two.
Good job.
I hear that you want to be a
YouTube celebrity.
Yeah.
- Or star?
So what is better to be?
Personally, for me it's better to be a star,
because you don't have to continue
put out that content.
But YouTube,
they don't want somebody like me anymore.
No?
- They don't want a video,
one video that gets 300 million hits.
They want somebody that produces 300 videos
that all get a million hits each.
Because at the end of the day
YouTube is a business,
and they make money by linking up
advertisers with audiences.
And so, if you have a person
that has 300 videos
that has a million hits on each one,
they have an audience of a million,
around a million people.
And they know how old those people are,
they know how much money
their audience makes,
they know where they live,
and they go to advertisers and say,
Oh, you're targeting
13-to 16-year-old girls
who live in a family of four
and their parents drive this type of car.
Okay, perfect.
We have this person who makes videos
and that's exactly who watches their videos,
They're driven by their advertising revenue.
Please subscribe.
YouTube changed virality
to suit its business model.
They promote and turn into stars
those who produce a lot of content
on a regular basis.
Again, YouTube updated our dream.
No more counting views,
from now on we count subscribers.
I need subscribers, I really need this.
If I don't get any subscribers,
then why did I even do this for?
Please subscribe.
I'm sad now.
The same change in the business model
led to a rise of genres and channels
And created a new class of YouTubers:
A child who opens toys and becomes
the youngest millionaire in the world.
A Transsexual who makes makeup tutorials
and sells products,
That was the full "Drugstore" look.
or a Swedish guy who earns millions
by playing computer games.
But the big change, focusing on
channels and subscribers,
also gave a boost to different and unique voices:
A political blogger;
What is Democratic socialism versus
what is Social democracy
A vegan Iranian
with five YouTube channels;
Why vegan?
Choose vegan
For yourself.
Or a creator, who does not answer to anyone.
Not even to the American army in which he served.
Let me tell them what you did in the desert...
Someone that millions like to hate,
but nobody can ignore.
Let's kill everyone inside and call ourselves patriots.
In short, a role model for me.
But if it was your family
I'm sure you won't be so thrilled
So you were serving in the army
and then you became a YouTuber.
What is the story?
When I was in the Air force,
we had this meeting in this big hall.
They asked everybody
why they joined the Air force?
They said college.
And everyone raised their hands,
almost everyone.
You know most everyone was there for themselves.
And the whole patriotism thing was…
nonsense.
And…
Americans that I'm serving with are pricks.
So I didn’t like that, it was draining.
And it was depressing, and…
And I wanted to be in a world that I admired.
And so I wanted to go into
the American YouTube community,
or just the YouTube community in general.
That's when I started making videos.
This was really exciting for me
because I didn't really have an outlet,
for that kind of creativity.
But not a lot of stuff happened,
until I was featured
on the main page on YouTube one day.
I'm a banana.
You're a what?
What happened to your clothes?
I'm a banana!
I'm a banana.
Look at me move!
So Onision,
who deals with political content
and doesn’t give a damn about anyone
hit YouTube's top page
only with a song about a banana.
And even Nasim,
the radical vegan activist
realized that for YouTube to expose her
to a new audience
she needs fake boobs.
So if I want people to see my political videos
I also need to make
thousands of videos
and occasionally flicker with a viral song.
So I make my way to meet two YouTubers
that figured out the formula.
Building a targeted community
around their channel.
If someone can make
even a crow like me sing it's them.
For they are
the Lesbian Duo.
We are Bria and Chrissy.
We are the Lesbian Duo
I always say that if you want to be
a successful YouTuber
and you really want to blow up,
then you have to find something
that hasn't been done,
or something that's been done
and do it in a different way.
Like for us, there were other
LGBT content creators,
there were other lesbians online
making videos,
there was no one
that was doing it and singing.
We're 'the Singing Lesbian Duo' of YouTube.
Yeah.
- Yeah. And whatever it is,
you have to find your niche.
I think your talking shirt idea
is really great.
Really something.
Hi, I'm a failure on YouTube,
my name is Itamar Rose.
Make the mouth a little bigger.
And maybe make it a little more positive.
Hi. -No, not higher pitch,
just you being positive.
My name is Itamar Rose,
I'm a failure in YouTube
but I'm going to be the most famous YouTuber
in the world.
Bah!
I think that's a really great idea.
- It's a hit.
Let's have your shirt sing a song.
Watch the magician.
You should go wild.
- Like this? -Yeah.
And I want to be a star...
It was good, the low was good.
You like that?
- Yeah.
Perfect.
- Great.
I am a talking shirt.
And I want to be a star
no one watches me yet,
Depressed, desperate for success.
Please watch me, like me, share me.
And hug me...
Subscribe me.
So thanks to Bria and Chrissy
I've made my first step as a YouTuber.
I found my uniqueness,
but this is only the first step.
So they learned
back in the 50's and 60's and 70's
that celebrities sold products.
And they're finding
that YouTubers
have huge influences
over their audience.
More than the regular celebs?
Definitely more than regular celebrities.
Because they've grown to trust them,
they've grown to feel connected.
You know, you meet George Clooney
or another...
or Brad Pitt, Angelina Jolie,
these huge movie stars.
We like them, we see them on screen,
but we don't feel connected to them.
But a YouTube person
who you see the day-to-day life
that they live,
it feels almost like a friend.
Our vlog channel is definitely our diehards.
They want to see
what we're doing every single day,
they're tweeting us all hours of the day,
commenting on every photo.
They have been with us
through ups and downs and so…
These people… for them we are
like family almost.
Good morning.
So I just had to go get a filling.
I was leaving and I stopped
by this coffee shop to get some water...
Share every detail in my life, even I can.
My life is no less boring than
those of the most successful YouTubers'.
There's a washer and dryer right here,
inside this building.
I can do it.
At least once a day I'm brushing my teeth.
When I was young
my parents didn't insist
that I will brush my teeth,
and then I have a lot, a lot of holes.
As you can see
I have here some blood....
Better not to learn from me how to do it,
But I want you to know me better
and to know I have a lot of...
problems with my teeth.
See you in the vlog tomorrow friends.
How is to be a YouTuber,
how is it to make it your life?
The glamorous side is
that you get to be your own boss
and have your own business,
your company,
and make your own decisions.
But the other side is being an entrepreneur,
you can't ever stop working.
- Keep feeding the beast.
It's constant.
So you must feed the beast?
Yeah.
- Six videos a week.
Six videos.
- No. You're not serious.
Yeah, serious.
If you now want to stop for...
you're tired and you want to stop
for three months.
No.
- What will be?
Our career would disappear.
It would disappear.
You think really it would disappear?
No, we know it would.
- I know it would.
So who is this terrifying beast
that Bria and Chrissy
have to feed with six videos a week?
What is an algorithm?
An algorithm is essentially...
we just mean the piece of the code
on YouTube
that decides what video should be ranking
where in the list, for what.
That's it.
How much you need to do a week
in order to...?
A minimum, a minimum of three videos
is generally...
three videos is generally
considered the minimum
for the algorithm not to hate you.
So now I understand why every YouTuber
also makes vlogs.
It's not for us, the audience,
but mainly because
that's what you can produce easily, daily,
to satisfy the beast’s appetite.
so I decide to go 24/7
and shoot my whole life
with a head cam.
With the amount of videos I upload
I can call myself a proud YouTuber,
but I still feel my subscribers count
can do better.
By the time I turned 22
I was an alcoholic.
What do you mean, it's over?
All of my friends started losing
their virginity in 7th grade.
Here's how they started calling me
Nickacado Avocado.
It's not enough to share
only the daily stuff.
I need to let go of my protections,
show my subscribers who I really am.
Yo, friends,
today some serious stuff.
It's very personal,
I have a serious problem with my wife,
from the moment the baby was born
she doesn't give me any attention,
I feel completely alone,
I have no sex at all, even not once.
Maybe you can give me some
digital love instead,
something like 1,000 views,
it's like having sex with her.
Do it for him.
He's so sensitive
I'm not sure he can handle a divorce.
Please, share, comment, like,
keep this smile on.
We are now in Berlin outside YouTube Space.
I am right outside YouTube Space Tokyo.
YouTube Space Dubai.
YouTube Space Mumbai!
After reaching 207 subscribers,
by sharing my poor sex life
I feel ready.
Professional YouTubers,
those who create daily content
and built a noticeable community
are invited to YoutTube Space,
which provides state-of-the art equipment
and fancy studios
for YouTubers with more than
five thousand subscribers.
Shit.
I don't have 5,000 subscribers.
I turn to Google, YouTube's father,
to help me deceive his naughty son.
I follow pages offering
to sell likes, views and followers
and finally reach the forum called black hats.
A place where view dealers,
click farm owners and hackers
manage the dark world behind virality.
I found one of the top hackers.
He lets me film
only with his face covered
I guess you want some likes,
some comments, some dislikes.
Can you fix all of it?
Of course, without it,
it won't be believable.
What you have to do
is just copy the URL of your movie,
you paste it here,
then you copy this list,
you paste it down here,
whoever is online
will immediately watch the movie.
I'm not sure, because...
Every YouTube clip that has many millions
of views started that way.
You say even Justin Bieber,
he's....
- Everybody. Everybody.
I remember when Gangnam Style
got started,
me and my colleagues were all very busy.
You're telling me big news for me,
that Gangnam Style
is based on fake views.
The first millions were fake for sure.
YouTube sometimes identifies it
and sometimes it doesn't.
Why they're not fighting till the end?
YouTube itself
is also being measured somehow.
They don't want to fight the fake views
because it will influence
their numbers too much.
Where will YouTube be without
the fake views?
400$ short,
but with an army
of 5,000 Russian subscribers,
I'm inside the YouTube space.
With my Hebrew political videos having
thousands of Russians fans
maybe the hacker had a point about the motivation
of YouTube to fight the phenomenon.
In one of the large studios in YouTube Space,
I found Karim Metwaly
a huge star in the Arab world
who created videos dealing with racism
and the approach to Islam.
This was my chance to see
a large-budget YouTube production.
Welcome to another edition
of fan video responses.
What?
All this equipment for just
another vlog from the couch?
What’s up Haithan?
I'm from Morocco And I want to know is
how to be confident of myself.
Okay, first off, I want to just say
it's... it's confidence.
Confidence could always be worked on.
And, you know, the wonderful thing
about this world
is that it's not all about beauty.
If you're worried about how you look,
I mean look, look at me, I got...
I'm balding, man, I'm balding.
So I would imagine that,
you know, it makes me less beautiful.
But in reality,
beauty is not always how you look.
So thank you, Haithan, Habibi,
and I'll see you next time.
Peace, love, unity and see you later.
Okay.
So that's one video.
Thank you, man.
So you're like a psychologist of...
Kind of, yes.
- Millions of people.
Yeah. Yeah. I know.
A lot of people who sit online, watch TV,
they don't have anyone,
they spend a lot of their time
on the internet
so they feel alone,
so that's why they connect
with a lot of YouTubers.
So I have to give back in a way,
and this is how I give back,
you know, talking to them one by one.
So being a YouTuber isn't only talking
about your life
but also listening to millions of fans
providing a shoulder to
lean on in tough times.
Okay, fans all over the world,
after you heard my stories,
it's time for me to help you.
The first question is from Mabuto,
from Central Africa.
Hi, Itamar, I love your videos.
Thank you.
I have a problem,
in my village we have no water,
some of the family members died,
I'm very, very thirsty.
What to do?
Mabuto, I have only one thing
to say to you.
Water is just another material.
Don't be so materialistic, you know.
I need water, I need food...
Be more spiritual.
You need to ask yourself
who is the real Mabuto.
To think about your self-confidence,
to believe in yourself, to be authentic.
Even if you need to die,
die as yourself, die as Mabuto.
Keep it real, be part of my gang,
stay in touch, love you Mabuto,
see you later.
So after saving Mabuto from dying
it's time to meet my fans
face to face.
So I go to where fans
and YouTubers meet off-screen.
And today it's day one of Vidcon in Amsterdam.
Check it out, we are in Amsterdam!
It's Bria and Chrissy!
Hello!
Welcome, PlayCon Israel!
I realize that everybody's walking around
with expensive cameras,
shooting vlogs,
and I can't figure out
who are the YouTubers
and who are the fans.
My name is Angel Baranes and I'm 16 years old.
I have 40,000 subscribers on YouTube.
I'm Ann Ben Zion
and I have 220,000.
If I don't feel like putting on BB cream
in the morning
I just take the concealer
and it hides everything I want to hide
really well.
The next product is this perfume
and an eyelash curler...
Hey, girls!
Who here loves fashion?
Do you spend over 500 shekels a month
on clothes?
I do all kind of collaborations
with all kinds of companies.
I have Adidas.
They give me clothes and money,
and for that I post on my vlog
with their clothes.
I sell in two weeks 10,000 t-shirts.
I was like whoa,
you serious?
That's my power?
When I see a teenager
selling tens of thousands of shirts
I understand it's an industry.
So I'm off to a convention open
to the YouTube industry only,
where they make things happen.
I have an audience of two million,
and I've managed to parlay my audience
into millions of dollars.
When I first started videos,
I kind of was doing videos
that were going to get me views.
But I wasn't getting brand deals,
I wasn't making money.
But I got to the point now
that I don't use anything like that.
Everything is lighthearted,
I try not to swear in my videos,
it's kind of building that foundation
and then kind of like changing it again
to fit brands.
So I'm on a level now where brands work with me.
If you don't know how a website makes money,
It's because you are the product.
they're selling you to advertisers, right?
My selfie cam!
The new YouTubers understand
that the audience is the product
they sell to the advertizers
Excuse me.
- Yes.
You're from Nestle, yeah?
Yes.
- I heard you talking before.
I'm Itamar Rose, I'm a YouTuber.
Itama?
Itamar Rose.
Yes.
- Eat my rose.
- Eat-a-my Rose. Okay.
Oh, that's you.
Yes, it's me on the shirt.
- Nice. Alright.
I feel that I can be a very good YouTuber
for your brand.
All right, well, tell me,
how would you sell one of our products?
Okay. -Okay. -On 9/11,
when I saw the building collapsing...
Yeah?
Oh my God!
I knew some guy that died there.
Uncle Jimmy!
I must relax.
Yeah. I can't go back to my management
and say I found a great vlogger
who's talking about death
and then resurrection through Nescafe.
I need branding that is...
But you need from happy to happy?
Well, maybe it's funny to..
But it just can't be death to brand.
Have a break, have a Kit Kat.
Can you work with that?
Oh my God. Oh my God. Uncle Jimmy!
I have to take a break.
So we are just products
and the algorithm is in charge
of matching us to the client, to the advertisers.
Algorithm's like,
no one knows what it is, besides like...
- Yeah.
It's like a puzzle,
and when you get close to working it out,
it changes. -Yeah.
Will we reach a point where an algorithm,
a code, an AI,
analyzes every single frame
of your video and the audio track,
Of course we will.
In the middle of the mingling
algorithm orgy
of YouTubers and advertisers
I'm glad to see there's still
some alternative creators
making different bizarre art.
So this is ASMR,
and it stands for Autonomous Sensory
Meridian Response.
It's really soft.
Hi, poopsies,
welcome back to another.
The Most Relaxing ASMR Video.
Ever Made series,
part 6.
So, if I will do it, you think
it can help me succeed in YouTube?
An ASMR video is usually watched
from start to finish
because the person will want
to fall asleep too
and right now the YouTube algorithm works
based on how long a video is being watched
so if you have a 100% of watch time
on your videos
it will immediately push you
to the top of the algorithm.
What a disappointment.
She whispers not to us
but to the algorithm.
We... we actually used to be a hub
for all the weirdo children
that just wanted to seek comfort
and dive into their art,
that nobody else out there accepted.
And now it just feels like every...
every third kid is in it just for the money
and just for the business.
Yeah.
- That's not...
That's not the honest platform
I used to know.
And it hurts.
I like to say that there have been
four generations of YouTube,
and we are in the generation
that is now... grew up with YouTube
as a part of their childhood,
NewTubers, I'm calling them.
They saw the success of Pewdiepie
making his millions.
Remember to subscribe
if you haven't already.
They saw how these platforms
can be star-makers
and now they're seeing it
as their opportunity
to launch their own personal brand
or their business.
Nasim the radical vegan, already knew
which side YouTube's bread was buttered.
People like me are not good
for big businesses.
The generation that was born to sell.
The "NewTubers".
Do you want a big company
to contact you and...?
Amen.
A hair-coloring or hair-gel company.
My dream is to with a company
or work for a company,
for a company to think I'm special.
For someone to say:
Wow,
he's a YouTuber,
we want to work with him.
It's always nice to see highly motivated kids
I'm a gamer and a vlogger
and I break into houses
and do extreme.
What do you mean, break into houses?
I break into houses.
I hop the fence,
my friend goes inside the house
and I film him from outside.
Would you get more views
if you killed someone?
No.
No?
- I'd get a lot of views,
but I'd also get a lot of unlike
and unsubscribes.
Even the convention's organizers weren't
comfortable about the net's effect on kids.
So they brought an expert.
So I have the pleasure of running
the largest center in the world of its kind.
Focusing on the relationship
between young people and the media.
We want to focus a lot on
the positive effects of media.
So let's keep that in mind
as where we want to go
in the next 40 to 45 minutes.
Focus only on the positive,
a great start for a balanced
academic discussion.
We definitely see so many incredible
opportunities of media for young kids.
So I've seen effects on...
Positive effects on literacy, language,
math, science, engineering...
So we can all relax.
Our children can surf as long as they want,
it will make them successful.
It's scientifically proven.
It's okay, like, the situation?
Yeah, it's not...
It's not nearly as problematic
as our popular rhetoric or our media...
our general lay conversation might suggest.
A little too convenient.
I felt as if I'm talking with YouTube's CEO.
So I ask her about it.
How much time are you the manager
of the place?
About four years, I guess,
as the director of this particular center.
And in these four years,
you had some partnership
or some funding from...?
- I've done some collaborative work,
and in those cases...
- With which companies?
I would not talk about them on air,
because I don't want to cause any problems
for any of my companies.
I will never find out the real story.
Because just after our talk,
the festival's director
kicked me out
claiming that I was asking
unprofessional questions.
The moment I asked a critical question,
I was kicked out.
Apparently on YouTube it was happening
on a much larger scale.
YouTube advertiser boycotts started
about five days ago
after some ads from big corporations
showed up in front of inappropriate content.
But the reaction has been countless
advertisers
threatening to or actually pulling out
their money from YouTube.
Hundreds of the largest companies,
from Coca-Cola to Mercedes,
have threatened to boycott YouTube
in response to the fact
that YouTube has put their commercials
next to violent
and racist content
like ISIS videos.
So YouTube decided to play it safe.
They stopped showing ads,
not only in ISIS videos,
but in many videos,
millions, that were out of consensus,
not pleasant,
that the algorithm profiled
as not brand-friendly.
As you know, the past year we have been hit
with YouTube's mass demonetization
of LGBT channels.
So we got engaged
and we're obviously super excited about it.
We uploaded the video
and within two minutes the video
was demonetized.
We couldn't figure out why,
the video is pretty PG,
except that it said "future wives"
in the title,
or maybe it was because two women.
YouTube, what the fuck?
Then we went through other videos
and I found out there was like
a hundred of our videos
that were demonetized
for really ridiculous reasons.
One of our videos, our "Proud To Love" video
that YouTube actually reached out to us
about four years ago...
To make the video.
In an email and said we would love for you
to make this video,
showing what it's like to love
another woman.
And now YouTube has demonetized it
for we don't know what the reason is.
What they do is they look at the title,
they look at the thumbnail,
and they say:
Is this even remotely, whatsoever,
something that could potentially
be problematic.
As a comedy satire channel,
why am I getting killed?
Why we removed our Wall Street Journal video?
Political, no money.
Is YouTube over?
About the Wall Street Journal -
political, no money.
Muslim edition about religion -
controversial.
Very controversial,
not ad-friendly, demonetize.
Smile more and be happy,
just don't express your opinions, guys.
YouTube became the Big Brother
who oversees and overhears everything.
Don't talk about being g-a-y.
Don't talk about being r-e-l-i-g-i-o-u-s.
Don't talk about
p-o-l-i-t...
politics.
Never talk about your own belief,
otherwise you will be discriminated
and censored.
YouTube is a political actor.
It has interests,
and it exercise power.
There is no information that is neutral,
there is no technology that is neutral.
I lost revenue on half of my videos,
so that's like 4,000 videos divided by two,
so 2,000 videos I lost ads on,
which means I just got, like, half fired.
We're at a loss at this point
and we just don't know what to do.
They fired a lot of people.
They went from having a job
to having a hobby.
I have been putting all of my money
into this channel,
and my survival basically
for the last five years...
And I'm probably going to lose
my home because of it.
So I am just beyond sad and frustrated
that I could not continue
to support myself that way.
It's really painful to see people
lose their jobs
their home, their life's work.
But I understand YouTube's decision
to please their advertisers.
After all It's business.
But the more I research,
the less it makes sense.
YouTube not only prevented ads
like the brands asked for
but hid and even deleted
millions of videos and channels.
So I wanted to talk to you about a video
That YouTube took down.
It was upsetting when the video got deleted.
And I'm pretty sure they deleted it for a reason
that was probably a misunderstanding.
They age-restricted my ab workout video.
Why they did that?
Because this is what they are doing
to vegan activists.
Does YouTube hate LGBT content creators?
So if it wasn't for the advertisers,
why did YouTube delete
millions of videos?
Including videos documenting war crimes?
In an effort to protect viewers
from violent videos,
YouTube has been deleting clips and channels
showing atrocities in Syria.
In some cases
those videos may have been the only evidence
out there of war crime.
Activists worry without this video proof,
crimes may go unpunished.
So maybe they made their big move
to clean up YouTube
from everything that distracts us from
our only destiny, consuming.
You are worried about economic incentives,
that's worrying.
I'm worried about political incentives
where particular partisan incentives
are being played and we don't know that.
Or is it political?
Did they wipe out millions of videos
from conflict zones
to show the leaders of huge markets
like China and Russia
that they don't need to worry
about Russian Spring, or Chinese spring
happening in YouTube ever again?
The revolution will not be YouTubized
I literally can't put into words
how angry I am.
This is Bullshit.
What is certain
is that they made this huge move
without providing explanations
to the public,
to the millions of YouTubers
who woke up to discover that
their lifework was ruined.
I asked YouTube a direct question.
I said: What do I need to do
to get my channel off of your blacklist?
And they sent me an automated response.
And as some of you know,
I've gotten billions of views on YouTube.
Okay? That equates to millions
of dollars for YouTube.
I've paid lifetime salaries,
no doubt,
of certain YouTube workers
and they can't even give me a response
that is human.
Today, terror inside YouTube headquarters.
We have a report of...
subject with a gun.
They heard 7 to 8 shots being fired.
We have 4 victims, who have all been transported
for gunshot related injuries.
Senior law enforcement officials
tell NBC News
the suspect is a woman in her mid-30s.
And multiple law enforcement sources
tell NBC News
she died at the scene.
The identity of the shooter, Nasim Aghdam.
She shot a man and two women
before taking her own life.
Growing on YouTube is not in your hands.
It all depends on who is
controlling your channel.
A few hours after the shooting.
Nasim's videos were deleted from the web.
She was wiped off collective consciousness
as if she never existed.
Yeah, a lot of people offer the argument
that, you know, it's a private company
and, you know, we shouldn't have a big say
in anything that goes on.
Yet at the same time
we're talking about a monopoly.
People have to step in and make sure
that this company isn't deciding
the fate of the entire economy
or our society.
And right now,
YouTube is deciding the fate
of our society in many, many ways.
It's a centerpiece of our society
and should be treated as such,
and essentially owned
hence operated by...
the overall community
and not just by a few people
who are... working
in the best interest of a dollar.
Really good.
Look at these moments,
all of these stories,
secrets,
revelations,
from every corner of the world.
I would have liked to tell you
that after everything that happened
I took my fate into my own hands,
left YouTube and took my art
back to the streets.
But in real life,
us YouTubers that invested many years
and most of our money
can't really leave YouTube.
Our channel belongs to them,
our subscribers are theirs to keep,
we cannot take anything.
YouTube is their tube.
We are not citizens,
we are just subjects without property,
without basic rights.
So until it changes
and we make YouTube great again,
I'm here on the street with my gang.
So my last advice is: Keep it real,
unless it's depressing.
Be authentic,
if you're not gay or something strange,
and raise your voice,
unless you're Syrian.
And don't be heavy.
Take it easy.
Buy yourself some nice stuff
and everything will be okay.
And if you think I'm whining about YouTube
just because I couldn't become viral,
so I have a video of my son,
who can easily break the internet.
But you know, the internet in the middle east
with all the wars is very weak
and anyway, my computer is broken now
but believe me,
it can easily get 100 million views.